everyone who has followed the kim and
kanye marriage knows
it has been a roller coaster of the
highest highs and some very low lows
but now they may have finally hit the
breaking point and listen love them or
hate them this is big
it really is because of two things the
kids first and foremost and
because nearly two billion dollars is at
stake
we have different views sometimes
i've seen him go through a lot at the
end of the day life is about being happy
it's been a rough year for the couple
we're told they've been living separate
lives
kanye's in wyoming kim's in la with the
kids
our source adds kanye and kim have been
trying to save their marriage but it's
been difficult
when he acts out she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to i've only
been diagnosed
for two years the failed presidential
candidate tweeted this summer that kim
tried to lock me up recently we're told
they've been focusing on their separate
businesses and that's where this story
takes a staggering turn
according to forbes together kim and
kanye are worth more than
two billion dollars we're launching with
a contour kit
kim's fashion and beauty empire is worth
780 million dollars
yesterday she became 200 million dollars
richer selling 20
of her cosmetics company to cody and
kanye's estimated worth
nice and she ago kanye has his 1.26
billion
dz empire kanye's assets are almost
entirely tied up in his brand
kim actually has money in the bank
forbes says the challenge in a divorce
would be
splitting up kim and kanye's joint
assets like their home
artwork cars and jewelry forbes
estimates that is worth a combined 70
million dollars
and that's where the complicated
negotiations are going to happen
you